Vous êtes 5 millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne YouTube ! Merci !
C'est donc l'heure de répondre à vos questions !
Y a rien dedans.
Est ce que tu pourrais nous montrer ton appartement?
Voilà !
À 60 ans, t'imagines tu faire encore des vidéos?
Bah pourquoi pas ?  Hein euh... Tant que je peux créer des trucs sur Internet le plus longtemps possible, ça me plaît.
Par contre, je pense que ce sera des vidéos assez différentes de celles-ci, hein ?
Je sais pas si t'as remarqué, mais quand tu portes pas de couches et que...
Ah merde !
Ton fils s'appelle Cyprideux?
*rire*
Comment a tu réagit quand tu as appris qu'il y avait cette rumeur de ta mort dans un accident de voiture?
Oh mon dieu !! J'adorais tellement ses vidéos.
Mais c'est moi?
Oh mon dieu mais c'est encore plus triste !
Hé? Champagne?
Champagne !!!
T'es viré.
Oui, pardon.
Elle était bonne;
On te voit toujours.
Ah oui c'est un grand angle.
Tu as quel âge?
J'ai 24 ans, et c'est plutôt bizarre de répondre à la question d'un cheval.
*hennissement*
Il te reste 1 heure à vivre! Que fais-tu?
Ok, d'accord, je vais sur un site de cul.
Non non non non, euh... je vais voir ma famille
*musique baroque*
Non non, je fais une bonne action et ensuite...
*explosion*
T'arrive à lecher ton coude ou tes omoplates?
Bien-sûr.
Combien de temps mets tu environ pour préparer une vidéo?
Alors ça dépend, hein euh... en tout cas le plus long c'est l'écriture, ça peut prendre des semaines pour que j'écrive
une vidéo qui me plaise. Bon après, le tournage et le montage, euh... c'est l'affaire de... de quelques jours voilà!
T'es pas mort?
Euh...
Si tu serais un Pokémon, tu serais le quel?
Alors, il y en a clairement un que j'adore...
(off) "Après des années de travail d'une équipe composée des plus grands artistes japonais,
voici le Pokémon le plus élaboré, le plus charismatique depuis la création du jeu, je parle évidemment de..."
Métamorph.
T'as une meuf? Si oui, à quoi elle ressemble?
Alors oui, euh... elle s'appelle Jessica, et voici une photo de nous deux.
Voilà.
Y'a t-il des jours où tu te dis que tu aimerais faire autre choses que des vidéos?
Alors c'est très intéressant comme question parce que j'ai... j'ai un petit peu réfléchi, et en fait la réponse est assez évidente,
il n'y a rien de plus épanouissant que de faire des vidéos pour moi aujourd'hui. Dans toute ma vie, c'est
ce que je préfère faire, voilà de tout... à part baiser, bien évidemment Jessica.
Quel est ton film préféré?
Voilà une question très compliquée hein? Parce que j'aime plein de films,
Big Fish, Shakira, Jurassic Park, Star Wars
Mais je pense que le film qui m'a fait le plus kiffé dans toute ma vie, c'est The Mask
Splendide!
Est ce que t'as déjà eu un manque d'inspiration?
Alors oui parfois tu sais pas trop quoi raconter.
Et le mieux dans ces cas là c'est de ne rien dire hein...
Et c'est quand tu ne cherche pas l'inspiration qu'elle vient le plus souvent.
Donc voilà faut apprendre à.... à gérer ça.
Et surtout à... à raconter des histoires que t'as vraiment envie de raconter.
As-tu déjà signé des autographes?
Non! euh... pour une raison très simple
C'est que je ne sais pas écrire.
Comment tu te sens quand tu regardes une de tes anciennes vidéos?
Comme ça!
C'est MonsieurDream, euh... aujourd'hui je vais vous faire part, d'un de mes coups de gueule.
Pourquoi tu fais moins de vidéos qu'avant?
Alors j'ais eu plusieurs fois cette question ça m'a pas mal intrigué
Et comme j'suis un grand journaliste d'investigation j'ai réalisé cette petite frise de mes vidéos depuis plus d'un an
et je ne pense pas faire de moins en moins de vidéos
Je pense en faire autant, surtout si on rajoute les bétisiers, et mes vidéos Cyprien Gaming si vous aimez les jeux vidéos.
En tout cas si vous pensez ça, ça veut dire que vous en voulez plus.
Donc... Donc ça me fait plaisir.
Voudrais-tu faire du muggle quidditch?
Alorrs je sais que le quidditch c'est le sport euh... dans Harry Potter parce que j'ais lu tous les livres.
Et ça c'est la version avec des vrais joueurs.
J'ai vu des vidéos sur internet.
Ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va arrêter la drogue tout-de-suite!
Ceci était un communiqué du ministère de la santé.
Tu pense toujours pécho après ça?
Alors...
Alors en... en vrai je vous ai menti.
Voilà je suis pas en couple avec Jessica.
ça va vous étonner mais c'était un photomontage en réalité.
Et en vrai je suis en couple avec Patricia.
Tu m'as appelé Cyprien?
Répond!
Who! Répond je te dis!
Voilà!
Ta réaction quand tu as eu 5 millions d'abonnés?
Yes!
Who who who t'es mignon tu fais moins de bruit! Okay?
Oui Patricia!
Voilà!
Et c'est qu'en fait j'ai 5 millions d'abonnés.
Tu baisses les yeux! Bien!
Est-ce-que tes vidéos sont vrais?
Absolument ! hein... le mariage homosexuel de ma cousine euh... le vol de mon ordinateur.
Tout ça est vrai!
Comment tu as rencontré Squeezie?
Alors c'est une histoire assez banal.
Aar... Aarrg...
Excusez-moi!
C'est... C'est pas grave c'est bon là!
ça vous dit de créer une chaîne YouTube avec moi?
Oh mais oui!
mais bien-sûr!
Voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui malheuresement euh...
j'ai pas pu répondre à tous puisque vous m'avez poser en tout euh...
25000 questions
Tcho!
sous-titres: Ronexx
En humoriste, tu préfère Kev Adams ou Gad Elmaleh?
Alors je préfère Gad Elmaleh parce-que moi aussi je rêve d'une banque.
*Rire*
Stop!
*rire*
*Rire*
*Cyprien qui rit*